hey out there you guys it's time for
another movie retrospective now I think
if I'm not mistaken this is the first
Hammer movie that we've ever done yeah I
think is it I think we mentioned it
before on the show you two on the show
before but you know CNN loop so these
are the first ones we've reviewed yeah I
mean I think I'd have to go back because
we reviewed a lot but I'm pretty sure
this is the first horror the first
Hammer horror are we done it's
interesting because I actually wanted to
do this one because shudder just added
three kind of a little bit lesser-known
Hammer films and I so I watched all
three of them and like they're all
pretty good but I probably this is my
favorite of the three that they added
this is they're all restored they look
they look good they really do yeah this
is twins of evil yeah now this is
actually this came out in 1971 it's
actually the third film in sort of like
a loose trilogy called the Karnstein
trilogy or Karnstein if you prefer which
are all sort of very vaguely based on
Sheridan luffa news Carmilla
which was kind of the og vampire story
wasn't it came out twenty-six years
before Dracula yeah and also had a lot
of that you know
lesbian vampire action which Hammer
loved so much yeah now the interesting
thing about this movie I will say okay
so the other two movies in the Karnstein
trilogy are the vampire lovers which
came out in 1970 and lust for a vampire
which came out now to sit in 1971 now I
will say I think the vampire lovers is
the best of them lust for a vampire is
not very good it's mostly just like in a
excuse to like show lots of tits which
most Hammer movies are but it's like the
cool thing about twins of evil and about
vampire lovers is that yeah they show a
lot of tits and like yeah there's a lot
of that going on but it also has like
kind of a cool story and like other cool
[ __ ] going on - yeah and Hammer films
had high quality to them to British me
at high-quality films they did yeah
yeah I mean
you know that's where they're making
Star Wars later on you know and if you
wanted cool special effects you could go
to England and you know those guys those
guys worked yeah and they look their
seventies movies but they don't really
feel like it too much they actually feel
more like an early sixties movie to me
like a super high quality early 60s
movies yeah that's because that's
because you it's just the way they
looked you know where they were shot if
you asked me I mean they do hammer did
make I mean obviously nowadays when you
talk about Hammer movies most people
think about the vampire movies which
this is a vampire movie also has some
witch hunting going on in there as well
but you know you think of Christopher
Lee and Peter Cushing and stuff like
that they made a bunch of other
different kinds of movies too I think
they made like pirate type movies and
like other kind of [ __ ] but they you
know they're very strongly
you know associated with the Gothic
tradition of horror which some of them
are very successful some of them not so
much did you ever see I think this was a
hammer film Dracula 18 1970 I think it
was whereas that was like Christopher
Leland yeah I think there's like groovy
groovy 70s plus vampires yeah there's
some about them though they just kind of
had a 60s feel to me I might have been
the hairstyles or something but the
quality's always it was always really
high on us oh yeah the way they were
shot production values caught those at
costumes sets everything and I mean
there is probably a lot of leftover from
60s because apparently I mean twins of
evil came out in 1971 so you know 1971
was still pretty much the 60s I mean
yeah it always had good-looking people
and I'm not bad women you find it happen
well the funny thing about this now I
should say that this was actually
directed by John Howe who was probably
most famous for directing guess what
legend of Hell house so that's probably
why I like this one so much and why it
has kind of like kind of a more
compelling story to it and [ __ ] like
that
this can't have other reasons but
initially this movie was supposed to be
called like vampire virgins or something
like that it was like I said it was it's
part of a loose trilogy that's sort of
kind of based on Carmela even back in
the 70s they had clickbait damn
you know I mean so they were gonna make
it vampire versions I'm not entirely
sure what the original version of the
script looked like yeah but when one of
the people working on the film like the
producer or something like that
saw the two twins in Playboy whose names
are Mary and Madeline Collinson they
were like the first actual twin you know
playmates of the month or whatever and
he saw them and he's like okay well
we're gonna put them in a movie and
we're calm it's gonna still be a vampire
movie but we're gonna call it twins of
evil yeah and and they're cute too yes
they're beautiful girls and the
interesting thing is you know I don't
think they'd ever acted before this he
just saw him and Playboy I was like hey
we need to put them in a movie because
they're super cute act it worked out
really well actually they were very they
were very good in it yeah um cuz kind of
the whole thing I'm like I said this is
mainly a vampire movie but there's also
like a witch hunting kind of theme to it
kind of you know the story revolves
around these two girls and they I guess
their parents died and they were from
Venice so they're like very fashionable
and everything so they end up having to
go and live with their aunt and uncle in
this little you know butt [ __ ] nowhere
town like an Eastern Europe or wherever
the [ __ ] it is and so when they get
there like everyone's just gaping at
them because they have these like super
fancy like green dresses they're dressed
exactly alike and you know okay with all
their curls and all there is you know
cleavage like yeah yeah probably a bunch
of silicon it's hard to tell you know no
the funniest thing it's like the thing
that cracks me up I love this movie so
much it is just like so charming to me
but I love how a lot of these Hammer
vampire movies particularly it's like
they they don't even like they have no
shame at all it's like there's just a
couple scenes where one of the twins is
like out with it with all her you know
dress on and everything like that she
just leans it's like hey right there it
it's like right in the middle of the
thing just like just like what booty
warrior said I've got no shame in my
game
the way that's the way a horror movie
murim film was you know I mean like you
know action you know and she delivers
her line and she just bends right over
and pick up this right like I said
they're not like you shake like a star
one of these news I was feeling it ever
pick and everything's just constant
downblouse this is like down blast the
movie Jaws downblouse the motion picture
[Laughter]
please tell me that there's like a
softcore porn movie cop if there's not
someone making it right now I'm gonna
make it down plows yeah it's gonna be
kinda like a Star Trek it's gonna be
like a Star Trek ripoff from Star Trek
the motion favorite okay yes blog
feature and all that [ __ ] we just watch
that yeah
but another thing so so twins of evil I
will say that the title is a little bit
of a misnomer because one of the things
about it is when these two twins arrived
in this like kind of backwards
superstitious town one of them is kind
of evil and one of them is like super
pious alike good girl so it's like a
good girl bad girl dichotomy and like I
said I think it's cool that they
actually is yes so they actually got two
twins yeah and the cool thing about it
and yes there's like a porn movie it
does yeah well you can tell that they're
not acting because like a lot of the
facial expressions they give each other
like you know what I mean cuz they you
know obviously they're twins and they've
grown up together so it's like they have
all these little like expressions they
give each other and I think like it
lends a lot to their characterization
yeah have to say though okay so they
arrive in this backward town I love how
they're getting out of the [ __ ]
carriage like I said these beautiful
like mint green dresses these big hats
and curls and everything like that and
like all the dudes in town who are about
to go boar hunting or whatever they're
just like oh well they're on each other
yeah that was that's like old school
eve-teasing is that they call that or
what there's probably there's probably a
term for it yeah but they so they are
sent to live with their next of kin who
are their aunt and uncle another uncle
happens to be Peter Cushing yeah and
he's actually it in a rare a sort of a
villain role um I don't want to say he's
really like the main villain of the
piece because count Karnstein who is the
vampire in the town he's actually the
main villain but Peter Cushing plays a
witch hunter in ghosts a vial it's a you
know with the b-but vial you know like
evil so I thought that was kind of funny
um you know he's got like the big round
crown hat and like the [ __ ] black
poncho and like the white knowledge so
he looks badass yeah he's got these guys
following him around helping him
yeah the Brotherhood yeah yeah and
they're basically straight up going
around in their little carriage and
they're just like they see this woman
like for example they just see this
woman walking through the woods like
gathering flowers in a basket she must
be a witch get her you know what I mean
and then they just like burner at the
stake because clearly yeah a woman can't
walk around the street like gathering
flowers you must be up to something and
they're all in on what they're doing
they totally believe it yes they're like
you know so it's like dude is a hundred
percent a lot of ways I mean Peter
Cushing has like you know his character
Gustav has kind of like a Redemption arc
I guess although I have to say that like
he murders like a really lot of innocent
women so it's like I'm not sure that
there's any of redeeming that like what
by the time he gets like near the end of
the movie you know with one of his
nieces help and like with his wife's
help gonna be like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] why are you doing this
they're just questioning he starts to
question it because what ends up
happening is that because he's so strict
I mean literally the first thing he says
because the two twins arrive they're
like when he's out you know burning
witches or whatever whatever it was busy
that he does I don't how much does that
pay man it must pay Allah s that's what
his job so just how like a whole boys
network it's just kind of like a club
yeah I'm like a cult yeah this meeting
al
barson witches well yeah and it's like
wait one of them says because I was just
I watched it a couple times for this
review and it's like one of them just
says hey there's this woman that lives
like out at the edges like she doesn't
have a husband Berner yeah yeah
immediately yes that's all the reason
they yeah I tell you what you know um
Cushing he has he has a disability to
kind of project a powerful aura around
himself
oh yeah movie yeah I mean you really you
really take it you know take him
seriously he comes across the suit he's
pretending to be especially in this one
and it's funny for a guy who probably
weighs about 150 pounds maybe 140 yeah
he really does have he has such like
charisma yeah and I thought I mean him
and Christopher Lee I think that's why
they were in so many movies and why
they're so fondly remembered yeah must
have been anorexic I mean damn he's just
bones well this movie - I should say um
see he was supposed to be he was in
vampire lovers which was the first movie
he was also supposed to be in the second
one which was lust for a vampire but his
wife got sick so they had to replace him
with someone else so his wife actually
died and then he ended up being in this
movie like not that long after she died
because he didn't want to like I guess
he didn't want to be in his house
anymore like without her so he was like
just he just started working and he was
live like in a [ __ ] ton of movies after
that hmm because you know like I said he
was who didn't weigh anything I mean it
he was very smooth but yet he comes
across as like ISA buggies big yeah but
there's nothing really to physically
spindly I loved his fake he has a great
face that got heavy molars that's
[ __ ] I know that's like kind of
wonder that tears like get his back to
you pulled that to make him look more
yeah gaunt and skeletal yeah he just has
such great it's just like a great bone
structure man it's just like you know I
mean I can see what he's got a great
skull yeah so I can see why he's in so
many movies like this and like I said
normally he plays a hero he's a vampire
hunter he's was which he is in this one
too but I kind of like it because they
weren't afraid to make him a morally
ambiguous character he's not a
sympathetic character not at all like
when you first meet him literally the
twins get there and he's out witch
hunting or whatever
and they're like hey so their aunt khadi
or whatever her name is and uh you know
she's they're like well you you might
want to like change into black dresses
because you're supposed to be still in
mourning even though it's been like more
than two months since their parents died
and they're just like what the [ __ ]
nobody does that in Venice it's like
it's been two months we were black for
two months and now we're going back to
our normal clothes and she's like oh
well you know this town is very
superficial and it's like you know what
I mean so literally you know Gustave
vile you know Peter Cushing's character
comes into the house the first thing he
says he's like calling them peacocks and
he's gonna like and he just starts like
[ __ ] on them yeah so it shouldn't be
surprising cuz like I said one of the
twins their names are Maria and Freda
Maria is the good one in Frida is the
evil one
so Maria is very religious and she's
like trying to you know smooth
everything over she's like oh of course
you know we'll change into some other
clothes or whatever but Frida is just
like not having it she's like look I
can't believe we had to like you know
move in this but [ __ ] middle of nowhere
and she's like and she and she rightly I
think is talking about the witch hunter
group and it's like you know they're
just picking on all these innocent women
and it's like they get off on it and
also this one and you've really kind of
sympathized with her because she's
probably right about that I mean the
fact that they're just going so it's
almost kind of like it's the way that
she's treated that makes her because
because she is kind of a little bit
rebellious and because she has been put
under these slick strictures in her new
household she immediately becomes
obsessed with count Karnstein who lives
in this castle up on the hill not that
far away and he is like a Satanist and
he's you know he gets turned into a
vampire kind of later on and then so she
gets super fascinated with him and wants
to be all in on that and so she kind of
turns to the dark side but it's
understandable you know what I mean just
because because of the way she's gotten
used to and she's just like a normal
girl she's not like terrible or anything
but it then she gets kind of sucked into
like count karnsteins you know world of
Satanism and human sacrifice and whatnot
what I liked about the movie those who
started off with the witch hunter guy
you know he's definitely a dick
yeah and he's definitely doing the wrong
thing by the time he gets done dealing
with this vampire he starts questioning
all the witch hunting and stuff that he
had done before and then maybe you know
he'd killed all those people for nothing
you could tell he's never questioned and
he's like women I was killing these
women and they really didn't have they
really didn't couldn't really do much
but once he can see what a vampire could
do he's just like well that's what the
supernatural looks right that's evil no
yeah that's that's what the supernatural
actually are not supernatural but
paranormal that's what the paranormal
rig looks like so damn I guess I killed
a bunch of innocent people and then he
kind of becomes it kind of becomes kind
of like a hero in a way having realized
that he was wrong
which that's not usual for a movie
that's what I mean that is in a way
that's why I probably like this one but
I mean like I said vampire lovers is
amazing but I like this one because it's
it's not afraid to have this moral
ambiguity it's like I said Peter Cushing
is usually the hero really the nominal
hero of this is the guy Anton who is
like the love interest of first Frieda
but then she kind of goes off the to the
dark side so he kind of gets in with
Maria cuz they look alike what's the
difference but you know animation that's
I'm just joking I guess yeah I guess you
could say that his character was kind of
like kind of like a dick who became in a
way like an antihero yeah probably be a
good way to describe it words it's an
unusual twist for it'll be of any time
of any kind it is and it's also an
unusual I think it's also unusual to
combine the vampire thing with the witch
hunting thing right usually it was one
of the achene oh you had Witchfinder
general with Vincent Price you had like
you know there's kind of blood on
Satan's claw like this kind of like
horror and stuff and then you had your
vampire movies but this will kind of
combine now the thing about it like I
said I guess if you're looking for like
you know a timeline of like where these
three movies fit together I've heard
that this one is kind of like a prequel
to the vampire lovers because really the
only thing that connects them is the
Karnstein family and in this one
Carmilla Karnstein who is called
Murakawa
in this one because in vampire lovers
she was called mer kala she had like a
bunch of names that were like you know
mix ups of Carmilla but she's actually
are
dead in this one and then somebody gets
killed like count Karnstein the main
villain he sacrifices a girl in a
satanic ritual because he's like oh all
this satanic stuff is getting so boring
I need a really do a human sacrifice and
blah-dee-blah
so the blood falls on Carmela's coffin
and she wakes up and turns him into a
vampire now another interesting thing -
that is kind of original is that in this
one if you get bit by a vampire
you don't necessarily turn into a
vampire unless you're an evil person who
is willing to take on the whole Satan
thing if you get bit by a vampire and
you're a good person you just die okay
so I thought that was kind of
interesting I can't really think and
there maybe there is but I can't really
think of another that's kind of a good
angle I know I like that that way you
can pass moral judgment on a vampire
like you accepted yeah and that yeah
that's exactly why the man and that's
what made him a bad person was I mean he
was already like one of those decadent
rich people it's just who was art he was
like raping peasant women and keeping
them chained up in the dungeon to play
with and all this other kind of [ __ ] and
then he goes full on into the Satanism
and into the human sacrifice and
everything like that and then the fact
that he brings kind of accidentally but
he brings Carmilla back who's like his
distant relation or whatever and she's
kind of like I mean she's only in like
one scene and it's not Ingrid Pitt who
played her in the first movie but she's
basically just like hey you know do you
accept the whole vampirism thing you'll
be undead and you can walk around and
he's like yeah that sounds pretty
awesome actually you know so you know
you have to accept Satan and he's like
yeah I can't do so so like I said he's
accepting it and now Frida also accepts
it at some pushy kind of reluctant at
first but then she's kind of dead why
not you know what I mean so she kind of
has like a tragic arc wears like a down
so like I said you can understand why
she does it because she's a little bit
rebellious at the beginning but she's
not a terrible person but as she gets
like sucked farther and further into
like no I said sucked though that was
funny I didn't end that but um you know
cuz vampires music as she as she gets
kind of further drawn into this into
count karnsteins world you know she just
starts to lose her more
compass like all together and you know
as you said as Peter Cushing's character
Gustav vile is actually finally coming
to terms with all the bad [ __ ] that he
did I mean murdering innocent women like
you do you're just kidnapping well he
thought it was real yeah they thought it
was real they thought there really were
witches yeah and I get I think he
basically just comes out and goes there
aren't witches there are vampires
yeah well it's on Felton that because
he's like look you know all these people
are going missing and they're like going
because count Karnstein has been
operating pretty much above the law
because he is like a favorite of the
Emperor so it kind of me like make some
it humbles his ass well and it makes an
argument like the movies kind of make an
argument to about like how this powerful
man can get away with everything while
all the peasants are just like well that
happened right right exactly and and and
it kind of goes into it doesn't like
come out and say this explicitly but
they're saying that you know Peter
Cushing's character the whole
Brotherhood it's like they really really
want to get count Karnstein because they
know he's evil but they can't get to him
because he's protected so they're going
after easier targets right you know
defenseless women and someone actually
does kind of point out point that out to
them yeah you know what I mean that
that's what it's like that's the guy you
really want you're too much of a [ __ ]
to go after him yes he's protected by
actually they're committing evil they
didn't know it but they were committing
evil on innocent people right so like
monsters you know between finally like
as it goes on in the you know he
realizes the vampires are real and stuff
like that and through discussion with
his wife who finally like calls him on
his [ __ ] it's like what are you
doing
also Anton who I wanted to say was
played by a David Warbeck who most of
you Lucio Fulci fans will recognize from
the beyond he was also in the black cat
I think so he's in this too
and he's kind of like the good guy so
between that he finally gets to you know
a point where he feels bad for like all
the [ __ ] that he did before so you know
it it's just kind of like got so many
different interesting aspects to it that
you don't really see in a lot of
Witchfinder movies aren't a lot of
vampire movies like I said that one more
you actually had to
except Satan I don't know how widespread
that trope is because you don't really
see it all that well it's well-written
gothic horror that's there's a lot more
modern then yeah we were used to you
know we're used to them you know
Frankenstein Dracula
that's 1800 stuff you know so this the
original stories were not that complex
yeah it was the beginning of the genre
well this stuff's all coming out of the
70s and you know whoever's right and it
understands the genre and they know the
formulas and they can come up with some
good twists to a gothic horror story
and I like the fact that you know they
kinda were taking certain things that
you would see in the 20s and the 30s
before all those damn rules came when it
came to making every taste kotor because
they're taking some of those elements
and bringing them up to 70 standards
because you know all these skimpy
outfits and all this sexual innuendo
that was going on back in the 20s and
30s Karloff and Bela Lugosi it's not a
long movie but boy there's a lot of sick
ass [ __ ] sexual undertones necrophilia
stealin people's daughters incest
multi-generational kind of people
learned incest their variant stuff like
that but it's just at different times
you could get away with more never
wearing sheer gowns that you could
basically pretty much see through and
you go man this is an old black and
white movie yeah and a human sacrifice
and sacrifice and a weird [ __ ] like that
in there Boris Karloff praying to Satan
and you know it sounds like an authentic
satanic you know speeches and [ __ ] well
I was before all those codes yeah and it
was an original story I think there was
20s there was a 30s black cap
pretty sure that was 30s the early 30s
and yeah early 30s and it had a real
cool Art Deco kind of style to it and
you would think that something like that
was coming out of a 70s but now ya old
there is it's a it's really amazing like
how dirties yeah there's this pre-code
movies there they got away with my [ __ ]
and then you know it was like so stayed
for like
a couple of decades and then finally
lino 60s and 70s came along and they're
like they just started putting whatever
went back to the pen and again it went
back to that and in hammer was like kind
of at the forefront of that I'm saying
yeah yeah it was a lot like a third
early 30s horror movie where they call
it like you know bloodletting and bosoms
yes kind of that was that was their
formula yeah it's so tickets evidently
people went oh yeah
pay for them damn boobs I mean yeah come
on but yeah I recommend black cats see
that when you price they have for you on
YouTube yeah you probably can yeah it's
like I can't remember what year it was
but I think I missed the first Dracula
was 1931 and I'm pretty sure it was
after that yeah I had nothing to do with
Alan Poe just that loosely based you
know just a lot of yeah based just
around that damn title yeah and I think
it's only maybe a 40 minute movie maybe
it's not long they made a lot of short
ones back I guess cuz it was just like
so tedious like much harder to make him
bet yeah and make the whole thing on a
computer but yeah so twins of evil like
I said there to the Karnstein trilogy
also shudder just added it they also
added another Hammer movie another
really good one called hands of the
Ripper which is about Jack the Ripper's
daughter it's not a spoiler alert
because they established that within
like the first two minutes of the movie
that that's who the killer is is checked
her first daughter that's also very good
and actually a fun fact was usually when
twins of evil played in the US it was
usually on a double bill with hands of
the Ripper a shudder also added another
Hammer movie called vampire circus
that's good one on which yeah it's that
was a lot more campy than twins of evil
but it's still pretty fun it's also tied
into twins of evil because they both
used the same sets
that's another boob fest and it's got
Darth Vader's in it that's right I
forgot yeah David Prowse defrosted he's
not like a it's not like a huge role
it's like a pretty small Roy's a circus
strongman for me yeah yeah he's a circus
strongman yeah yeah so that one's also
pretty decent so if you have shudder
like I said you might want to check
those three out and like I said as far
as I know I think this first Hammer
movie we did I hope it's not the last
one because I like a lot of the hammer
he put them out there
yes so maybe they'll add some more and
we'll do some more but yeah twins and
evil go to shutter and check it out